[Music]
hello and welcome to this video yeah
this is the first video in our video
series about how to fight efore like
Fabiano karana does yeah and what does
he do he plays d4 d5 the double king
pawn opening almost yeah for sure the
most popular reply on the top level
nowadays they almost yeah almost all the
top players have a 45 in the repertoire
but then it's a matter of taste I guess
how will they continue against the main
lines pretty much regardless what you do
against the main lines you also need to
have something ready against all the
sidelines that white can throw at you
and this first video is about two very
aggressive sidelines that we should know
some good replies against we are dealing
with in this video the move d4 which is
not yet really does not yet have an
opening name because the next move after
our capture will determine how the game
is headed and the other move that we're
going to check is the infamous Kings
gambit yeah the Kings gambit is a very
yeah aggressive opening of course and
something that we need to have some good
reply against so I suggest that we start
with the move d4
okay against D form our choice is easy
we will take the pawn yeah anything else
is just too passive so we take it this
is a general principle that is basically
applying throughout the whole repertoire
it is also something that is not yeah
something that I invented the one that
is pioneered here if you can take a
central pawn in the open game
double King pawn you should almost
always do so it is a much more passive
way to play for example to defend the
pawn with a move like d6 yeah you rather
want to take and open up the game so
here
black takes the pawn and now White has a
choice of of moves I have to emphasize
already that after deform on white is
struggling for equality that it's just
what it is the same thing we will see
with the King's gambit the early gambit
continuations really nothing to be
afraid of if you know what you're doing
so d4 it takes before what does white -
probably the the main line here is Queen
takes deform which is not a gambit yeah
of course but it often gets to a very
sharp play so it definitely belongs into
this first chapter gambits and the text
what other moves does white have one
move that is important for us especially
because we play the petrov against 293 a
move that is important for us is the
move Knight f3 why is that important
because the normal-looking move Knight
to c6 actually transposes into a scotch
game which is not bad for black but
totally outside of our repertoire okay
you can play knight c6 if you also have
that in your repertoire anyway but I
don't think that is even the best move
the best move I think is the one that
I'm recommending Bishop c5 you can also
play Bishop b4 check by the way that's
also quite okay
yeah bishop before check we're very
likely after c3 be a gambit that black
can take but Bishop c5 is I think a very
strong alternative there are a couple of
reasons why I think that this is good
white now it has two basic choices he
can make real gambit out of this with c3
now on the next move or you can just
take the pawn we should look at the
gambit first maybe
that can be started with c3 or Bishop c4
it were very likely yeah it can easily
transpose it to one another
so if c3
[Music]
you